Kevin: Hey, everyone! My name is Kevin. I'm a tester with fable. Today I'm doing a self-guided task.
Kevin: The task is called Record a do sighting.
Kevin: and the
Kevin: slug is, you.
Kevin: O, see? Aye. RGS. Dash 7.
Kevin: The technology configuration that I'm going to use today is switch control on my Ios.
Kevin: You can kind of see on the screen there that there's a little
Kevin: cross hairs going back and forth. This is what I'll use, and I'll use some of the settings built into the Ios switch control software. The task today is I will be going on a website, and I will be recording a goose siting with some
Kevin: fake data. And then I'm going to go through that. Enter that data. And then, once I'm done.
Kevin: I'm going to go try to change some of that data to see if the functionality and the flow works. Okay. so here we are at the starting point for the page, saying, record a goose sighting.
Kevin: So there are some links on the screen here. I'm just gonna check those links to make sure they're gonna be working. Okay.
Kevin: we'll go to environment countryside. There we are. Go back. That one seems to be working.
Kevin: And I was going to wildlife and biodiversity. Yep, you can see when I click on. Those those ones are active.
Kevin: not gonna go any further with the cookies or anything. It's not really part of the task. But I just wanted to make sure that those white guys were working. So let's start the process. It says, use the service to tell us if you like. Geese tell us what type of geese you saw
Kevin: and the date on which you saw the goose. So
Kevin: I think there's a start. Now, option here. I'm just gonna use my switch control to scroll up there. We are.
Kevin: Well, click, start now.
Kevin: So this is a very easy question. Select if you like, East today I do like geese. The purpose of this task.
Kevin: and then I'll just click on. Continue. Everything seems to be working fine. Tell us what type of goose. It was
Kevin: because I mean Canada. Of course we've got to use
Kevin: a Canadian goose. So right put that in.
Kevin: I would normally use my voice to type this in. But we're we're on a zoom call.
Kevin: My microphone gets disabled. So I'll just have to type it in
Kevin: spare letter by letter. But typically, I would use the microphone down bottom and use that to to populate anything. It's just a lot faster than going with letter by letter.
Kevin: so we'll create a can of goose.
Kevin: Luckily we have some word prediction here which is helpful
Kevin: to
Kevin: not seeming to want to predict this word. So wherever we go.
Kevin: so we'll click done to disable the keyboard. It's nice at the keyboard. Things come up for that option when I clicked on that text box.
Kevin: Okay, so now it's looking for a day, a month in here that I saw the goose. So let's go in today. See what populates.
Kevin: Oh, this is great! I love. This one date, month or year comes up. I love it when the number pad is populated as opposed to the general keyboard, just because there's obviously less buttons that you have to hit.
Kevin: So let's say today. So we are going to say the first day of March, which would be 0 3,
Kevin: and I don't know if what the format will be for day am I who viewed afterwards? But you'll see. and then 2 0
Kevin: to 0
Kevin: to and 4
Kevin: looks like it's kind of like the example up. I probably didn't have to do that, but we'll see what happens.
Kevin: He likes it.
Kevin: So here are some of my answers that it was before it says, Do you like geeks? Yes, I can have the option to change that.
Kevin: As I said, I'm using some of my scroll down options. I have recipes built in that do certain gestures.
Kevin: one being scroll up or scroll down. There's the other option. I can use 2 for somewhere you can actually doesn't seem to always work. That's why I had the recipes. It doesn't always
Kevin: highlight where you're going, where the actual here we go. There's a scroll command, too, so you can scroll up
Kevin: or scroll down scroll left scroll, right?
So
here we are. So I'm actually gonna change the type of goose that I saw.
Kevin: Ask me to do that. So I'll click on the change button. And this time we're going to see a different type of booze. so we can change that. So I will change it to.
Kevin: I don't know any types of geese, but we'll just put something in
Kevin: green-headed green goose with the green goose. Why not
Kevin: to?
Kevin: And
Kevin: we'll call it the Green Goose.
Kevin: and we'll hit. Continue again.
Kevin: It's gonna ask for the day a month again, I'll change that again. So it's
Kevin: we'll keep that for the same day. I don't think it matters
Kevin: one
Kevin: the
Kevin: and we'll do
Kevin: 2,024,
Kevin: or
Kevin: I'll collapse that number pad and
Kevin: continue.
Kevin: And there we go. It did change it. So I'm going to just review everything. It looks like all the answers are right in there. I'm going to. Then the last part of the task
Kevin: is just to hit. Continue and send the application. Let's make sure that works too. and continue.
Kevin: There we are. We have a goose recorded science. Oh, there we got some nice pictures of some geese eating in a field.
Kevin: So overall, this experience was quite good.
Kevin: My switch controls seem to work no problem with the web page. All the links were active. I was able to scroll up and down.
Kevin: change the data as we required, and then submit the application. So
Kevin: I would give this
Kevin: this website a good good 2 thumbs up for
Kevin: for accessibility based on the task that I was providing. And yeah, that's pretty much it. So I have a wonderful day, and thanks for watching.